nein also ich habe ja eine eine sehr
schöne these mitgebracht weil wir haben
ja in dem vorgespräch viel gesprochen
und ich habe gedacht na ja ich bringe
eine ganz besondere these mit und zwar
schnell mosen deutschland ein land der
jammerlappen es ist ja heute so dass wir
ja ich meine vom ländern das ist jetzt
ein schöner übergang wir haben ja heute
ganz viele große themen immer wo sich
und sagt wo immer aufgeregt wird und es
ist eigentlich alles furchtbar und
sobald irgendeiner jetzt in irgendeiner
art und weise sich nicht abgeholt fühlt
dann wird natürlich gleich großer terror
gemacht und quasi die anderen die das
gesagt dann sind wahrscheinlich auch
fast schon extremisten und wie können
sie das noch sagen und wie geht das
eigentlich unter zum beispiel ist
passiert denn und ein autounfall und
alle politiker sagen geben wir müssen
jetzt alle strassensperren damit nie
wieder ein autounfall passiert und
überhaupt alle diese ganzen themen und
früher hat man ja sowieso ich sage mal
auch politisch du weißt es ja selbst man
hat quasi debattiert egal welche partei
man isst man hat über irgendwelche
themen gesprochen in der familie bei
freunden in der eckkneipe überall und
danach hat man bier getrunken und zwar
eigentlich alles wieder in ordnung heute
ist das ja ganz anders heute wird ja
sofort ein quasi nein du bist jetzt darf
es gar nicht mehr mitspielen weil du
hast dich gar nicht gegen an die regeln
gehalten und so geht es gar nicht und
ich finde quasi dass wir heute in einem
land sind wo man im grunde gar nicht
mehr wirklich sagen da fasst man jetzt
denkt und ich sag mal so wir leben ja
ein ende der inhalt demokratin ich bin
auch selbst froh darüber dass wir dort
leben aber es wir sind so empfindlich
geworden wir haben in wir sind in einer
zeit kommt in der es derart also alle
sind mimosen quasi alles wird sofort
ganz zart besaitet genommen und ich sag
mal so ich bin erzogen worden von meiner
großmutter und meiner mutter meine
großmutter war jahrgang 21h seit dem
krieg mitgemacht und da war durchaus
sehr viel disziplin und wenn ich meinen
teller nicht aufgegessen hat dann dürfte
ich gar nicht aufstehen so lange bis ich
auf gesetzt würde wurde mir letztens in
einem gespräch schon das ist ja nicht zu
fassen das ist ja kindesmisshandlung wie
kann man das machen und sagt na ja das
ist nicht meine großmutter auf eine ganz
andere generation das kann man nicht
heute sagen na ja aber das hat meine
großmutter hat dem krieg nichts deswegen
und du willst jetzt nicht essen du
bleibst so lange sitzen wie du bist du
auf gegessen hast und jetzt wird quasi
alles quasi als extremismus als ganz
bösartig und so und ich zum beispiel
würde sagen ich mir das gar nicht
geschadet aus mir ist ja was geworden
also irgendwie ich stelle mir gesagt man
traut sich nicht mehr also ein land wo
man sich nicht mehr an die meinung zu
sagen haben sie dafür ein praktisches
beispiel wo sehen sie sich nicht mehr
trauen ihre meinung zu sagen also in
meinem beruf ist ja an sich sowie
künstler dürfen ja ein bisschen mehr als
andere und und gerade bei so bunten
kunden wie mir ist es ja auch die
möglichkeit da kam ich jemand sagen na
ja ich bin ein lustiger konnte und die
darf das schon aber zum beispiel ich
habe eine ganze weile lang den song auf
der bühne gesungen zigeunerjunge von
alexandra und daraufhin wurde mir dann
irgendwann mal in einem live stream hat
mich jemand angeschrieben hat
geschrieben dass sie verboten es liedgut
singen das ist ein assist nazi
terminologie und habe ich gesagt um
gottes willen das liebt es von alexandra
nicht von leni riefenstahl
also ich weiß ich das ist ja schon eine
merkwürdige art und weise und jetzt ist
mir das schon öfters passiert dass leute
sagen du kannst zigeunerjunge lied nicht
mehr singen so den ganzen tag oder haben
sie komplett gesagt hat ich sehe ist
natürlich nicht mehr weil ich die diesen
ganzen dialog diese diskussion ist mir
so anstrengen wenn ich dann von der
bühne runter komme autogramme geben oder
mit fans sprecher und mir danach anhören
muss man wie gern sie das sehen ja wohl
nicht wahr sein so und ich sag mal über
mich ich sage aber ich bin eine bunte
und also wenn jetzt jemand sagt man ja
dass die lustige darunter stücke stört
mich dass ich für mich auch überhaupt
nicht angegriffen oder beleidigt aber
andere machen ja das ist ja wie ein
riesenfass aufgemacht wenn man sich sagt
so was zu sagen und ich habe letztens
rechtes noch ergänzen darf eine kollegen
gesehen die ein konzert gemeint
zigeunerjunge gesungen hat auch von
whatsapp geschämt gesagt du hast es
gesungen du bist aber mutig hat sie
geschrieben ja es hat auch noch niemand
etwas gesagt noch nicht na also man muss
jetzt so aufpassen und und das finde ich
ist eigentlich eine gefährliche
entwicklung weil ich finde wir müssen
eigentlich auch über alles reden dürfen
und danach uns auch auf augenhöhe und
mit rückgrat wieder ins gesicht gucken
können ohne dass wir gleich
vorführung in die luft gehen auch
bosbach finden sie das liebt
zigeunerjunge sollte man auch singen
dürfen ja dass das wirklich tatsächlich
das ist ja jetzt nicht provokativ
sondern stammt aus einer zeit in der
[ __ ] schnitzel gegessen und [ __ ]
so benutzt wurde ohne dass man damit an
die diskriminierung verbunden hat wenn
es jemand sagt ich würde ich kann die
auch verstehen will irgendwann sagt man
sich die lebenszeit ist begrenzt ich
will mich nicht mit sowas bestimmt schon
mal so eine situation wie sie gesagt
haben ich will den ärger nicht mehr ich
lasse das thema jetzt seien
mit sicherheit mehr als eine
manchmal muss man einfach dadurch und
muss an ein das lasse ich mir nicht
bieten und dann erklärt man auch warum
ich kann mich noch erinnern anders ich
habe mal mohrenstraße [ __ ] apotheke da
habe ich mich mal mit beschäftigt weil
das mit mauren zu tun hat hat er das
überhaupt nichts mit einem schwarzen
menschen zu tun und ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern dass ich mal einen
anderthalb seitigen brief von der
antidiskriminierungsstelle der caritas
bekommen habe man sich von farbigen
gesprochen habe ging ja nun gar nicht
und habe mir beim englischen im kopf
gehabt people of colour also ich kann
sagen dass ich nicht gut aufgepasst habe
aber das hier ist für mich immer farbe
im englischen geht's im deutschen geht
es nicht also lasst sie es jetzt auch
weg ob man da anders darüber schreiben
muss eine andere frage jedenfalls war es
überhaupt nicht diskriminierend gemeint
ich erwische mich selber dabei und mir
ist das nicht recht dass schon mal links
und rechts kurve hast du jetzt irgendwas
gesagt worüber sich einer aufregen
konnte das sind ja zu 99% leute die sich
aufregen wollen die davon leben sich
aufzuregen um anderen die meinung geigen
zu können und wir müssen uns alle man
bisschen lockerer machen ein bisschen
fröhlicher werden man kann auch fleißig
arbeiten aber dabei fröhlich sein
sie betonen um so ein bis drei schüler
bei dir ein beispiel wie gesagt es gibt
korridore die mein lieber in realität
das ist das was mich ärgert die
korridore wären immer enger und es gibt
ich bin da weiß nicht ob genetisch oder
biografische irgendwie mit man mit einem
gewissen renitenz gehen ausgestattet
will mir eine ansagen machen will dann
wird es extra engen für den dass das
dann so geht es nicht das problem ist
aber gesamtgesellschaftlich wenn es in
augsburg im hotel drei [ __ ] gab was
jetzt umbenannt worden ist dann gab es
den vorschlag lasst uns doch wenigstens
eine tafel an machen wo wir daran
erinnern dass hieß 400 jahre sogar ganz
vorbei der ganze mich sagen brechen
und eine probe und wir liegen aber
obwohl junge oder sind die junge fällt
auch ginge aber das führt vom thema weg
aber das problem ist doch dass und
authentische daran es muss doch möglich
sein zu erinnern dass hier 400 jahre
dieses hotel stand mit dem namen oder
das die mohrenstraße zum beispiel wenn
ich es richtig weiß mit mehreren
schwarzen zu tun hat die irgendeinen
friedrich anfangen des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts
nach berlin gebracht hat die wohl sehr
gut hier in dieser straße gelebt haben
in jedem falle muss man doch geschichte
so erinnern wie sie ist und darf sie
nicht einfach tilgen wir haben wir
schneiden uns da das ab was mir gewesen
sind und wo wir mist gebaut haben dann
sollen wir es gefälligst auch dran
schreiben wir haben ein afrikanisches
viertel in berlin da will man die ganzen
straßen umbenennen um daran nicht zu
erinnern dass jahns war ihr ein relief
das bundesgericht ja und verwies damit
müssen wir leben und wir dürfen doch
nicht nur die interpretation gelten
lassen als ob wir es sozusagen noch
immer verheerend da hängen lassen
sondern wir lassen ist auch als zeichen
unserer schande so haben wir gedacht vor
300 jahren und natürlich haben wir in
afrika nicht immer eine segensreiche
rolle gespielt aber aber eines ist auch
richtig worte sind ausformulierte
gedanken wenn es eine nennenswert große
gruppe gibt dich sagt ich fühle mich
durch das wort [ __ ] diskriminiert
würde ich da auch rücksicht darauf
nehmen wie groß müsse der gruppe sein
nein ich jetzt zahlenmäßig aber wenn es
zehn prozent der sinti und roma wäre
würde ich sagen ja aber wenn es 70 80 90
oder wie fast alle sind dann würde ich
sagen ja würde oft die gruppe auch
rücksicht nehmen es gibt allerdings auch
gruppen die darauf bestehen so genannt
zu werden ist auch nicht in rumänien und
in ungarn und im ganzen osteuropäischen
raum ist sie gerade noch nicht das ist
euer operette zigeunerbaron so
diskriminierenden titel hat sondern man
muss das in den historischen kontext
stellt der bundesgerichtshof hat ja auch
zu einem relief [ __ ] nicht gesagt
richtig so sondern hat gesagt mit den
erläuterungen die ist doch gibt der irrt
der historische kontext hergestellt